wow you are fluffy like you got some
gnarly waves kind of energetic hi I'm
Leo I may seem very sweet but my real
attention is to steal your socks and
your heart I love a good tug of war and
of course I'm the life of the party
wherever I go like my mom I require lots
of attention but I promise at least with
us it's never boring very fluffy but
doesn't jump on me so that's kind of
cool in a way yeah Leo's being
surprisingly chill around him does your
mom have hair like you you don't know
okay he's very friendly so I'm assuming
the the mom is very friendly as well
like I would see the owner being more of
like going out on Hikes a lot very
active I think we made a good connection
though I don't know if he necessarily
likes me but I kind of like him he's
cool